la petite vie gaz bar blues ding et dong
les voisins certains lions était l'un
des camions les plus en vue du québec
puis silence radio il a disparu des
écrans radar les documentaristes martin
fourni et pierre luc latulippe l'ont
retrouvé sa conjointe en a en fait qu'on
a rencontrés en premier qui étaient
dehors qui prenait un café puis on a un
petit peu parlé avec m on s'est
présentés et to pay and vraiment informé
que c'est impossible de le rencontrer le
pot dans sont pas actuellement puis
surtout quoi dans son étude ça faisait
comme plusieurs années qu'ils étaient
certes époque qui voulait absolument
avoir personne en effet depuis six ans
les seules personnes qui l'ont vu son sa
conjointe leur fille et un sympathique
couple qui habite dans le demi sous sol
sous son appartement et qui tente de lui
venir en aide on trouve souvent des
bonnes personnes c puis entre eux rester
rare de rencontrer des gens qui avec un
aussi grand car ceux qui veulent tous de
tout donner puis à tous les jours puis
et quand tu les obtiens qui est
justement à s'oublier ils ont entrepris
de documenter le quotidien des proches
aidants de serge thériault et leurs
démarches pour le convaincre de sortir
de l'isolément des proches qui souffrent
eux aussi de le voir si mal en point en
fait la grande question de ce
documentaire l'eau c'est comment on peut
faire pour aider une personne qui
souffre mais qui veut pas recevoir nice
serge thériault est omniprésent dans le
film sans être devant la caméra comme
une présence fantomatique lui qui n'a
rien perdu de son esprit qu'on a réussi
à y parler est vraiment passé un peu de
temps avec lui effectivement il n'y
avait pas perdu tous deux sont de ce
qu'il est et puis c'est quelqu'un de
d'admirer de drôles naturel quelque
chose de force en fait c'est quelqu'un
qui marque un contrat confirme au delà
du drame humain dior serge d'or est une
ode au courage et à la solidarité des
projets dans montrer la boue la beauté
et la bonté des gens car c'est ce qui
est important pour nous ces gens là pour
nous c'est des gens de coeur n'y a pas
beaucoup de gens de coeur sur la planète
quand il y en a il faut les foules et
glorifié il faut leur rendre hommage le
film dehors serge dehors sera présenté
aux rencontres internationales du
documentaire de montréal avant de
prendre l'affiché à montréal le 19
novembre et de partir en tournée au
québec ici nabi alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal